spin the ball right from a rumored
romance to a surprise proposal your only
word was here's what bachelor nation is
doing during quarantine let the journey
begin
former bachelor Ben Higgins proposed to
his girlfriend Jessica Clark when I
asked her to marry me she didn't even
say yes she just shook her head up and
down and I said is that a yes and she
said yeah the happy couple exclusively
told et how it all went down I started
to say this is a really special walk and
I started Terra because I looked at her
and she hadn't started crying yet but as
soon as I started crying and she started
crying but she didn't know why she was
crying yeah she said it was one of two
things either I was ending our
relationship which would have been a big
shot or we were I was gonna be proposing
been planned to pop the question in New
York where he and Becca kufran were set
to stop on their Bachelor live on stage
tour but with a corona virus outbreak he
had a plan B but this is exactly how I
would have wanted I mean would have been
magical and special in its own way but
it's really cool that we just got to be
together last night and let's take a
second to appreciate that gorgeous ring
Colton Underwood is seeing the light at
the end of the tunnel after testing
positive for coronavirus I woke up this
morning and I felt like a new man I feel
like the medicine has started to work
and I've lost a lot of the symptoms that
I used to have there's no more fever
body aches the 28 year old still has a
mild cough but it's a total 180 from
this main thing is I can't even walk up
a flight of stairs without being out of
breath or the bathroom without having to
sit down because I'm exhausted yeah but
that was just two weeks ago moments
after he received his test results The
Bachelor alum said he was scared for his
life I think that the scariest part is
the unknown nobody knows what this thing
does how long it's gonna last if it has
any perm
image I mean I don't know if I can get
it again or if I could relapse so I it's
just a scary time right now
girlfriend Cassy Randolph and her family
helped speed up the recovery process has
kind of given you a new appreciation for
Cassie and her family as they have
nursed you back to health
a hundred percent um it's been so
incredible literally having Amy like be
my little nurse and Cassie be there for
me masks and gloves on supporting me and
eating breakfast with me six seven feet
apart and Matt has made some killer food
for me while I was recovering so it's
been good for all of us I think I told
you and Chris it's been like a home town
mixed with a happy couple all at the
same time and it's been fun as fun as
you can make it and quarantine and in
isolation but they've kept me in really
good spirits the romance rumors just
won't quit between Hannah Brown and
Tyler Cameron there was emotion still
there you know she's an incredible
person an incredible girl the two have
been totally inseparable since isolation
from the super flirty vibes I can't take
the country out of the girl I guess to
the body contact
and the pillow fights seems like these
two are definitely dating right I do not
know the fans have their own theories
some seem to think they are sleeping in
the same bed Exhibit A
Tyler getting fake mad at Hannah for
changing the sheets Exhibit B
flash-forward a few days ago and we have
Hannah cozied up in the same bed I mean
the similarities are compelling so I'm
going to leave it at that
even though Tyler and Hannah haven't
confirmed that they're dating we are
living for their quarantined videos
quarantine more like borign teen things
are also getting weird in bachelor
nation quarantine more like
Florentine yep that's Kaitlyn Bristowe
posting a video on Instagram with
chocolate on her face Jordan Rogers is
now doing dog squats and Nick vile is
finally in a relationship with his mop
yeah you
[Music]